qui un rapport très important qui a été
publié au cours des dernières heures
rapport du giec le groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat
donc dévoilé et qui a été préparé par
une centaine de chercheurs de
cinquantaine de pays pour la première
fois par une majorité de hauteur de pays
en développement ça c'est important
et avec nous souhaitons pour commenter
ce rapport caroline brouillette qui est
chercheuse senior un changement
climatique chez équiterre bonjour
caroline bonjour qu'est ce qui ressort
de votre lecture quelles sont les
grandes lignes du rapport
mais ce rapport en fait qui viennent
nous expliquer quels sont les liens
entre les changements climatiques puis
notre utilisation des terres donc l'état
on les utilise pour l'alimentation pour
l'industrie forestière mais également
pour les bioénergies
ce que le rapport vient nous dire c'est
dans un contexte où la population
mondiale augmente ça crée beaucoup de
pression pour la sécurité alimentaire
puis également les changements
climatiques viennent ajouter à ça donc
nous dire que si on continue comme ça il
ya des gens qui vont vraiment mourir de
faim de plus en plus oui et c'est déjà
le cas en fait il ya 800 millions de
personnes qui souffrent de la faim déjà
aujourd'hui dans le monde ça va
augmenter
ça va augmenter puis déjà on gaspille
également 30% de nos ressources
alimentaires sont gaspillées
donc le rapport de nous informer le
désert du trash des mesures comme ça
quand on regarde un système qui est un
peu paradoxe paradoxal qu'on peut
prendre pour améliorer la situation
et puis les solutions passent par des
gestes très très concret et très
individuelle si je peux dire parce que
on dit aux gens vous devez idéalement la
changer votre façon de vous alimentez
oui tout à fait en ce qui concerne
l'alimentation lieu deux grandes mesures
qu'on peut regarder c'est d'abord
réduire l'apport la consommation de
protéines animales partout dans le monde
c'est quelque chose qui est déjà en
marche on voit l'offre de produits
végétariens et végétaliens augmenté mais
également changé la façon dont
l'agriculture se fait c'est une
révolution alimentaire qui doivent faire
c'est pas juste les comportements
individuels mais aussi comment
l'industrie travaille la terre comment
on peut travailler la terre de façon à
absorber le carbone de laisser la terre
est re ce tampon là entre l'atmosphère
et le reste de la nature c'est pas
simple quand on connaît les procédés
actuellement l'agriculture
non c'est ça c'est une transformation
qui est radicale mais également qui est
déjà en route au québec par exemple de
2007 à 2008 une augmentation de
l'agriculture biologique de 30% qui a
été remarquée chez équiterre nous on
travaille avec un réseau de fermiers de
famille qui nourrissent chacun 250
familles par alain billaud si vous êtes
là dedans le sauf que quand on parle
d'une production à grande échelle pour
les milliards d'humains que nous sommes
à ce moment là faut vraiment changer de
façon radicale important ça va coûter
très très cher ça va coûter cher mais
comme je disais tout à l'heure il ya des
arbitrages assez évident par exemple la
réduction du gaspillage alimentaire
c'est un nombre énorme bon français il
ya également la restauration des milieux
naturels par exemple les tourbières les
prairies ce sont des milieux qui absorbe
beaucoup de gaz à effet de serre donc
les restaurer leur permettre de jouer
leur rôle naturel celui qu'ils ont joué
depuis des millénaires
c'est une action plutôt simple qu'on
peut prendre dans la dernière année là
c'est pas le premier rapport du giec qui
est à déposer en a eu un
l'automne dernier dans lequel on disait
aux politiciens de ce moment où vous
devez agir et c'est possible de le faire
mais il faut beaucoup de volonté des
jeunes très concret cette fois ci mais
non on parle de l'agriculture quand vous
avez terminé la lecture de ce rapport de
j
vous l'avez terminé dans quel état
d'esprit avec espoir optimisme ou
d'effectuer une passe à l'avenir il faut
jamais tomber dans le défaitisme c'est
sûr que c'est un rapport qui confirme ce
qu'on sait ce qu'on a ressenti par
exemple cet été avec les vagues de
chaleur les inondations les sécheresses
les feux de forêts dont entendu parler
cela étant dit ça renforce l'importance
d'une action de tous les secteurs qui va
nous permettre de rester dans une
augmentation de température sous un
point 5 degrés celsius
il nous reste onze ans pour le faire le
giec nous donne un rapport qui est plein
de solutions comme je disais tout à
l'heure des solutions pour lesquelles on
a déjà commencé le travail donc faut
juste accéléré mettre les politiques
publiques qui vont nous permettre de
faire embarquer l'industrie non
seulement les choix individuels aussi
puis on peut y arriver vous pensez que
les politiques vont embarquer dans le
train il ya eu beaucoup de
manifestations à travers le monde dans
les derniers mois les jeunes
en suède et un peu partout dans les
grandes villes vous pensez que les
politiciens vont emboîter le pas je
pense que la mobilisation est plus forte
que jamais les électeurs les citoyens
envoient un message fort à leurs
représentants à ce moment là bas je sais
la question c'est est-ce qu'ils vont les
écouter ce qu'ils vont faire les choix
les bons choix pour pour qu on restreint
et les événements les plus
catastrophiques les au changement
climatique
mais je préfère m mais même dans
l'espoir avec de l'espoir car une
brouillade merci beaucoup d'avoir été
vendu ce matin
merci bien